THREE YEARS EARLIER THAN
PREVIOUSLY EXPECTED.
SOCIAL SECURITY IS ON PACE TO
BECOME INSOLVENT IN 2034.
CONGRESS IS BACK TO WORK TODAY
HOUSES ON IMMIGRATION AND THE
SO-CALLED DREAMERS.
IN THE SENATE, THEY MAY BE DOING
MORE WORK THAN PREVIOUSLY
EXHIBITED.
CHIEF CONGRESSIONAL
CORRESPONDENT MIKE EMANUEL HAS
THE STORY.
>> SENATE MAJORITY LEADER TELLS
COLLEAGUES TO BUCKLE UP FOR A
LONG, HOT SUMMER.
IN THE HOUSE, A GANG OF RENEGADE
MODERATES TURNS UP THE HEAT ON
LEADERSHIP.
MAJORITY LEADER MITCH MCCONNELL
BLASTED DEMOCRATS FOR
OBSTRUCTION.
>> I THINK WE HAVE ENOUGH WORK
TO DO FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
THAT WE SHOULD BE HERE DURING
THESE WEEKS.
I HOPE YOU WILL GET GREATER
COOPERATION, BUT EVERYBODY
SHOULD ANTICIPATE THAT WE WILL
BE HERE.
>> SENATE DEMOCRATIC LEADER
SUGGESTED PRESIDENT TRUMP SHOULD
STAY IN TOWN TOO.
>> WE ASSUME HE WILL BE HERE IN
WASHINGTON WORKING RIGHT
ALONGSIDE US.
>> IN THE HOUSE, SOME G.O.P.
MODERATES TRYING TO BREAK UP
GRIDLOCK ON IMMIGRATION.
TWO MORE DEMOCRATS HANGING ONTO
THE.
ORGANIZERS ARE THREE SHORT OF
THE 218 SIGNATURES NEEDED TO
FORCE VOTES ON IMMIGRATION BILLS
JUNE 25.
AS HOUSE REPUBLICAN LEADERS TRY
TO FIND A G.O.P. SOLUTION.
>> WE ARE VERY CLOSE ON A COUPLE
DIFFERENT FRONTS.
IT REALLY BOILS DOWN TO HOW ARE
WE GOING TO HANDLE THE DACA
RECIPIENTS.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP WAITED ON
IMMIGRATION THIS MORNING:
"SEPARATING FAMILIES AT THE
BORDER IS THE FAULT OF BAD
LEGISLATION PASSED BY THE
DEMOCRATS.
BORDER SECURITY LAWS SHOULD BE
CHANGED BUT THE DEMS CAN'T GET
THEIR ACT TOGETHER!
STARTED THE WALL."
ARIZONA REPUBLICAN SENATOR JEFF
FLAKE SAYS THAT ISN'T HELPFUL.
>> I HAVE WORKED WITH DEMOCRATS
ON IMMIGRATION.
THEY DON'T WANT OPEN BORDERS.
THEY DON'T FAVOR MS-13.
I WISH HE WOULDN'T MAKE THOSE
ACCUSATIONS.
>> ATTORNEY GENERAL JEFF
SESSIONS ISSUE THIS WARNING TO
THOSE CONSIDERING COMING HERE
ILLEGALLY.
>> WE DON'T WANT TO DO THIS AT
ALL.
PEOPLE DON'T WANT TO BE
SEPARATED FROM THEIR CHILDREN,
THEY SHOULDN'T BRING THEM WITH
THEM.
WE'VE GOT TO GET THIS MESSAGE
OUT.
YOU ARE NOT GIVEN IMMUNITY.
>> THE ACTING HEAD OF
IMMIGRATION AND CUSTOMS
ENFORCEMENT OFFERED THIS ADVICE
TO LAWMAKERS.
>> IF YOU WANT TO DO A FIX ON
DACA, LET'S TALK ABOUT THE
ISSUES OF IMMIGRATION AND FIX
IT.
SO WE DON'T HAVE A DACA EVERY
TEN YEARS.
>> IT'S NOT CLEAR IMMIGRATION
WOULD BE DEBATED AND VOTED ON IN
AUGUST.
McCONNELL HAS SAID HE'S ONLY
INTERESTED IN TAKING UP A BILL
PRESIDENT TRUMP WOULD BE WILLING
TO SIGN.
CUTTING SHORT THE RECESS.